please welcome alicia silverstone
[Applause]
i love you we've been friends a long
time we've known each other for many
years i'm hearkening back to do you
remember when you and i went out um we
got dinner and then we went to a
drive-in movie
yes i'm glad you remember of course we
had the best time
yeah that was really fun that was our
first date it was our first date i love
when we were younger together
and um you posted this pic this
throwback and then i reposted it the
next day immediately look at us
look how cute you are oh my goodness
i mean
come on we were at the nickelodeon kids
choice awards in 1988
1998 that makes more sense
88 was a rough year i was 13. it was not
pretty
but
you know
i i wouldn't trade it for the world
and your son bear he's 10 now
he is i'm gonna just kick it really
quick to the cutest tick tock that you
and bear
did together
um
where you're as cher i mean you've blown
up on tick tock everybody take a look at
this video
cheer get in here what's up daddy what
the hell is that a dress
says who calvin klein it looks like
underwear
i mean
you look exactly the same
how cute is he with those huge glasses
on his face and big jacket just he's
such a little baby
do you know what's crazy is the vin
diagram of josie geller for me
and cher horowitz for you is the costume
designer mona may
did both movies both characters like she
is the connection yes moname's brilliant
genius
i mean oh my gosh share is a fashion
icon you had 64 costume changes
yes
were you yourself a fashionista at the
time
no
clothes were not my thing at all and i
did not get it even though i so
appreciate and respect and admire mona
now at the time i was like leave me
alone i just why do i have to try all
these clothes on
and then when you saw the movie was it
like
then i got it that it all made sense
her work appreciates more and more with
time it's so good
yeah it really does really big shout out
to mona may right now who created all
these iconic films and characters
um
now
the babysitter's club freaking out we're
now moms how is it doing this great show
season two this is so delicious and i
will say also that watching this with
your kids is just the perfect sweet spot
it's true bear and i watched it and he's
a boy and he's watching all these girls
on screen and when he saw season one he
loved it so much and i felt proud as a
mom
because
i thought this is really wholesome it's
so innocent and pure but they deal with
complicated things so you can feel good
about your kid watching it it just makes
my heart happy the costumes in this are
really fantastic
and it's very bright and energetic and
it's just sweet i don't know i love it i
couldn't agree with you more it makes me
very emotional too and i love that your
character also
is single and sort of you know finding
herself and her
new way in the world um
with kids and i myself am figuring that
out and navigating that so when i watch
something like that i immediately
connect and i'm curious to see what's
going to happen how it's being handled
and so i thank you for that that i can
watch this with me and my kids we're on
tracks that the show is on and um
i
i understand that you're single and
out there um
and in the dating world i am too i am
curious how you're navigating it
how long have you been navigating it
um
well definitely after i got divorced i
waited years but then my friends i think
almost were looking at me like it's been
three four
five years and i'm like oh okay well
i'm not okay
and so you start to realize maybe i
should put my toe in or try and then you
try and it's like it's a little bit of
an
earth shaker because you're like uh
okay
how do i do this whole
dating app thing because that's what it
is now like when you and i used to go
out and meet people in person then
there's covid and it's just this is the
new world and i mean you can tell how
flustered i am talking about it but i'm
also i'm also fascinated by it
[Music]